Then here we have a few more technical terms: payload, total flying weight and wing loading.
Wing loading is important to know what the flight behaviour of your wing will be.
If you load a wing more heavily, it becomes much faster and more agile.
If you load it more lightly, with about 3 kg per square metre — we always calculate in kilograms per square metre —
then the wing becomes much slower and more sluggish and also less demanding to fly.
And depending on what your requirements are, you can choose the wing loading accordingly.
However, it's mostly defined and recommended by the manufacturer this way,
that between this and that takeoff weight you take this size, and the wing loading then results from that.
You normally don't calculate it yourself.
But if you're in an intermediate range in terms of weight, right between two sizes,
and you're not so sure which wing you should choose,
then of course you're a bit slower with the larger wing
and a bit more sporty with the smaller wing, which however also demands higher skill.
Wing loading is always the total flying weight divided by the projected area.
With the total flying weight you have to be careful that it's not the payload — they're not the same thing.
So the payload is actually everything except the wing — everything that hangs on a paraglider.
For wing loading, however, you have to include the wing in the calculation.
So the wing, even though it flies up there independently, also counts towards the wing loading kilo per square metre.
And the easiest way is, if you actually with your backpack, with your whole flight equipment,
with the sandwich, with the drink, with the hiking shoes, everything that will be in this package in the air later,
stand on the scale and then you have your total flying weight.
Then we come now to the glide ratio.
An interesting topic, it's always discussed a bit at the launch site too.
Hey, what's the glide ratio of your wing?
And it's always difficult.
Manufacturers don't lean too far out of the window on this either,
because in the end of course it depends much more on how you fly and how you bring out the potential from the wing.
Because mostly within the same wing class the wings are so similar, differ in such a small range when it comes to glide ratio,
that it's much more important how the handling is and how comfortable you feel with this wing,
than having this wing where, hey, it has half a point more glide ratio.
But what is a glide ratio at all?
A glide ratio is the ratio of your vertical distance,
vertical, I have a slip of the tongue, sorry,
vertical distance and horizontal distance
and this ratio for most modern wings comes out somewhere between 8 and 10.
High-performance wings are perhaps...
a bit above that, while a school wing is between 8 and 9.
I've taken 9 here in the example.
That means, with one metre of altitude we travel 9 metres.
With 1,000 metres of altitude from launch to landing site you can theoretically fly 9 kilometres.
And that's of course a very theoretical value.
You always have to consider that you might also have some sink,
maybe you have headwind and then the ratio of speeds looks of course quite different again.
And when I plan a flight, I usually don't assume the 9 or 10 either,
rather if I want to calculate, hey, I want to get over the forest up there,
then I take maybe a glide ratio of 6 or 5, if I want to be really conservative
and not get myself into a problem.
That's one way to calculate the glide ratio, namely the distance you travel along both axes.
The other is speed.
You can also say,
my wing flies 10 metres per second horizontally and loses about one metre per second.
Then you're again at a glide ratio of 10.
But you can also simply take lift divided by drag
or the lift coefficient divided by the drag coefficient
and you'll always arrive at the same value, the glide ratio.
And there you see again, to the topic we had earlier,
if drag of course becomes smaller and smaller, that means,
if lift stays the same, that means our glide ratio grows and becomes larger.
Something else that's a bit confusing for the theory exam:
the glide angle is not the same as the glide ratio.
So a large glide ratio is something good.
It means we fly far.
But that means that the glide angle is small.
And if the glide ratio is smaller, as in this example 5,
then the glide angle is larger.
So the glide angle is always relative to the horizontal.
So we can now take the ground here and our flight path.
And when the glide ratio is better, i.e. larger,
then this angle decreases more and more and becomes smaller and smaller.
Then we come here to the speed polar.
It's of course very theoretical here now.
We've heard a bit about it in flight practice already.
Ultimately you simply have to know what to do in which situation.
Because you're not always in absolutely zero-wind conditions,
where the whole air is actually standing still.
Rather we have lift, we have sink, we have headwind,
sometimes we may have tailwind.
And you can control your wing via the brake and via the accelerator
so that you can always get the maximum out of the wing
and travel as far as possible or stay up as long as possible.
I'll try in the next few slides to show you a bit
what happens to these points on this graphic
when we have wind influence.
Basically in trim flight, that is, when we simply leave the brake alone,
the paraglider is built exactly so that it glides as well as possible.
That means we're at best glide.
We now have the red line, that's the whole speed range of the paraglider.
From the far left, from the stall, that is, if we brake even more there,
then the flow detaches, we're too slow, we no longer have enough lift,
the angle of attack is too large, we're no longer flying.
From there on we can release the brake.
The wing becomes faster, it transitions.
Here we're at minimum sink.
At minimum sink the glide ratio isn't quite as good as at best glide.
But we sink the least.
Ultimately, though, it always depends on having the best possible ratio
and not on one speed or the other.
Then we have here, as said, the trim speed at best glide
and when we then give more gas, when we accelerate up to maximum speed,
Vmax written here, then we're at the fastest speed.
In ratio, if we worked out the numbers here,
so 13.5 divided by something like 1.8,
then this value is smaller than if we calculate here 10.2 divided by 1.2, for example.
We don't have to crunch through the exact numbers now,
but the ratio is always best where the tangent, the green line,
touches our state curve, that is, our speed polar.
Now let's work the whole thing out with headwind.
You see, with zero wind the green line starts at the zero point at the top.
If we now have 4 m of headwind, we can simply start the line further forward
and draw it down like this, and then we see,
from here to here our points wander further towards maximum speed.
If we have even more wind, like 7–8 m per second,
then the tangent wanders further and further forward
and the point of best glide is then at some point,
when we're fully on the accelerator, at full throttle.
Where exactly that is and at how much wind, that's of course very wing-dependent.
So every wing is a bit different, that depends on the loading.
There are then very many factors that you can hardly figure out by calculation.
Best in practice is, if you have any GPS device with glide ratio calculation.
When you have headwind sometime, you can just try things out with the accelerator.
What happens if I half-accelerate now?
The glide ratio will probably get a bit better.
What happens if I fully accelerate?
If the glide ratio decreases then, you back off a bit on the accelerator again.
And this way you can learn to optimise and figure out,
with how much headwind do I have to give how much gas, so that I glide as well as possible.
That now gets quite into detail or quite into advanced paragliding.
For the theory exam the four terms are surely very important,
so that you know when you have to accelerate and when you have to brake.
The more-braking comes into play with tailwind.
You see, here we have zero wind, here we have some tailwind,
here we have more tailwind and the orange point of best glide,
the tangent, wanders higher and higher up here, towards minimum sink.
Minimum sink is about 15–20% braked, lightly braked,
so that you sink less.
Because the tailwind, if we take it positively, that is, in this tailwind band,
we actually want to sink as little as possible.
Because the wind pushes us from behind and thus we automatically have a good glide ratio.
And we actually want to drift along as lightly as possible with this tailwind.
So to speak.
In lift exactly the same happens.
You see, when I go down here with the green line,
then the orange point slides again closer to minimum sink.
That also means going a bit on the brakes again.
And if you have a lot of lift, it may well be
that it falls even further over, so we have to brake even more.
That's very, very theoretical now.
Because if we're in a 2-metre thermal core for example,
it doesn't really matter how well it glides either.
So you'd rather fly such that you keep the wing controlled and in hand,
because then you're probably circling anyway.
It's rare that you'd just be climbing 2 metres in straight flight.
It does happen, but I'd say it's rather rare.
And if you've climbed so strongly that the point of best glide is way back there,
then you're probably circling anyway and not distance flying.
And if you're circle-flying, in such a nice climb,
then it's also much more important, as we've heard before,
to shift weight in flight practice
and centre the thermal as well as possible —
that's then much more efficient than precisely fiddling with the exact brake position for best glide.
With sink, in sink we can also say,
a sink, you actually want to leave as quickly as possible.
Headwind as a rule is something that can last rather longer.
So we just have the wind that goes down to the ground,
but there's always headwind.
With sink it also comes in addition, in practice this usually only happens briefly,
in a sink area.
And there you can basically just say, just accelerate,
get out of the sink area
and on top of that the glide ratio in accelerated flight gets massively better.
That's actually the conclusion, that you accelerate in sink and headwind.
How firmly that is, that's very wing-dependent.
In lift and tailwind we fly lightly.
When you brake, you can imagine,
there's already a positive momentum that we receive.
We have tailwind, we have lift.
In this air mass we actually want to drift along as long as possible,
that's why we brake a bit.
In headwind and sink we actually want to get away and fight against it,
so we give a bit of gas.
Very important when accelerating of course,
that you only do this with enough safety distance to the slope.
Also if you have a landing where there's quite a lot of wind all the way down to the ground,
better come off the accelerator with enough safety reserves
and maybe land standing or even backwards if the space allows.
If you've planned everything correctly, you've somehow also really got enough space to land,
than flying full accelerated all the way to the ground.
Because when you fly accelerated, the collapse risk is of course increased
and the wing's reaction is also more violent.
Therefore, at sufficient altitude come off the accelerator
and then concentrate on a landing.
Here it's depicted graphically a bit of what I described earlier.
When we have headwind, our flight path steepens considerably.
So the angle gets bigger, the glide ratio gets smaller.
When we have tailwind, it's exactly the opposite.
Then our glide ratio gets bigger and the angle gets flatter.
And that's simply the reason, because we always sink at the same rate.
With the paraglider it's actually pretty much irrelevant what air mass we're in.
It just has to have a certain speed, a certain sink,
to generate this lift.
We always sink, let's say, to make the maths easy, at one metre per second.
If we have even more headwind, so that the headwind is as strong as our speed,
we still have exactly the same one metre of sink.
So that means, we don't stand still,
rather we just come straight down with one metre of sink per second.
That's what you just can't get rid of.
Except you're in a thermal core or in a dynamic lift.
We're talking here about a horizontal headwind.
That's this example.
Actually, when it comes to calculations,
physically you always talk in metres per second and not in km/h,
because then it's just easier to calculate,
because the time units are always in seconds.
The conversion factor is 3.6.
So from metres per second to km/h is 3.6.
And with the paraglider it's quite handy for calculating,
because most paragliders have a trim speed of about 36 or 35 km/h.
For the example let's say 36 divided by 3.6.
That gives us 10 metres per second.
So we now have a paraglider that flies 10 metres per second forward
and sinks one metre per second.
That gives us a glide ratio of 10.
A very good wing.
Here we hit a sink field,
where the air additionally also sinks one metre.
So we move relative to the air, we sink one metre,
but the whole air package also sinks one metre per second now.
That means, in sum we have 2 metres of sink afterwards.
So on your variometer you'll see minus 2 metres per second.
And that then means that our glide ratio decreases massively.
That drops it from 10 to 5.
Because we only fly 10 metres forward, but have 2 metres of sink.
10 divided by 2 then gives a glide ratio of 5.
Then we have the movements around the 3 axes on a paraglider.
We have the lateral axis.
When a paraglider keeps pitching up like that and is a bit nervous,
then you say it's not very pitch-stable,
because it pitches back and forth around the lateral axis.
Then we have the longitudinal axis.
That's rolling or wingover flying.
Although wingover flying is a combination of many axes.
But you say the movement around the longitudinal axis is rolling.
And that would be roll stability.
If a wing doesn't fly straight stably, then it's roll stability.
And then we have yaw stability.
That's the vertical axis, which actually runs through the pilot and through the wing.
With this movement, when the wing keeps doing this in the air,
then you say yawing.
You also notice the stability.
In practice it's important that you've heard it once,
also for the exam and so on,
but especially now for the theory exam,
you just have to know the technical terms.
Stable, unstable and indifferent.
When you build a paraglider,
so every manufacturer actually wants
to build a paraglider as stably as possible.
Because if a paraglider is stable,
then that means that after a disturbance
it returns to the starting position.
So you can imagine it a bit like a bowl.
And if you let a ball drop into it,
then it always ends up rolling at the lowest point.
And if you give it a push and it rolls upwards again,
it goes back and forth a few times and at some point it's back in the middle.
So it's like when you fly straight with the paraglider
or accelerate, then release the accelerator,
the wing returns to the starting position.
From the left side, the wing turns off slightly to the right,
it pendulums two, three times back and forth
and the wing flies straight again.
So a beautifully stable system,
which also works so well on a paraglider thanks to the fact
that our centre of gravity hangs so low.
But that's actually the goal of a paraglider manufacturer.
Unstable you can imagine
like turning the bowl upside down
and placing the ball on top.
So you can give the ball a push
and it actually only gets worse.
It can never independently find its way back.
It just takes a breath, a gust of wind
and it tumbles down and gets faster and faster.
And the same with the wing.
That's for example a wing that you launch
and that afterwards gets faster and faster
until it gets a frontal collapse.
These are all things
that earlier in paraglider development
you had to discover in practice.
And then there are the technical terms for them.
Indifferent is then,
when a wing maintains its flight attitude.
So if you give a ball a push
on a level surface
and now assume
it has no rolling resistance,
it just rolls on and on, just straight.
It doesn't settle, it doesn't get faster,
it just rolls on straight.
Like when a wing
is hit by a gust of wind from the left
and then instead of
pendulating two, three times back and forth
and flying straight again,
it just goes into a curve
and maintains the curve.
That's the difference between unstable, stable and indifferent.
I hope that perhaps with
these bowls and these balls
you can remember it a bit better.
Then we come on to curve flight.
In curve flight
a load multiple is created.
So you see again,
vertically is gravity,
which pulls downward.
When we fly straight,
we have 1g, so one times
our body weight.
When we start flying the curve,
then the g-forces increase.
And you can calculate it
with angle calculations,
but you can also draw it out.
And if you draw it,
you can actually measure
and you'll find out
if you make a 70-degree angle here,
that the curve force, Fk,
at 70 degrees
is exactly three times as long
as your gravity force.
And at 60 degrees it would be 2g,
so two times longer
and at 45 degrees it would be 1.4g.
So 1.4 times more
than your own body weight.
In curve flight,
this is also a statement from an exam question,
in curve flight
load multiples increase,
that means more load on the whole system
and the minimum speed
also increases.
You can compare it a bit
to loading a wing more heavily.
So if you would hang a new solo wing
as a second one,
that would have the same effect
aerodynamically speaking,
as flying a curve
of 60 degrees
and 2g acts on the wing too.
Namely your whole
speed polar shifts
massively forward,
so
every element of this polar
simply gets faster.
Your trim speed becomes faster,
your maximum flight speed becomes faster,
but also your stall
or your stall speed
is higher.
In curve flight you have to be careful,
because the flow,
so a fast, extremely fast
curve is still no guarantee
that no stall can happen,
because at higher wing loading
you also need more speed
so that the flow doesn't detach on you.
Happens in practice
rather less,
because we also have much higher disturbance pressures
on the brake.
But still important to know,
that all speeds increase,
so both the minimum speed
and the trim speed
of your wing,
as soon as the forces get higher.
Right, then I'd like to thank you
for your attention
and hope that I could help you again a bit
in this part too
and that you go into the theory now
motivated,
study the booklet well,
work through the questions
and then go to the theory exam successfully
and pass.
And that hopefully also
in practice
one thing or another makes a bit more sense
or perhaps
a lightbulb has gone on for you in this area.
Many thanks, see you soon.